[موسيقى]
في قلب العاصفه من جديد لكن الرياح لا
تجري بما لا يشتهيه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق فحسب بل تهدد سفينته بالغرق هذه
المره
سيتم توقيف المرشح الجمهوري الرئيسي
والرئيس السابق للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الثلاثاء تظاهروا واستعيد
بلادنا بهذه الكلمات اعلنت ترامب عبر منصه
تروس توقعه بالقاء القبض عليه يوم
الثلاثاء في منهاره خلال مثوله امام
المحكمه وحس انصاره على الاحتجاج لكن مدير
مكتبه اعلن انه لم يتلقى اي اخطار من
المدعي العام باعتقاله وان تصريحات الرئيس
مبنيه على تسريبات مكتب المدعي العام في
نيويورك استدعى ترامب للادلاء بشهادته في
قضيه دفع مبالغ ماليه لممثله الافلام
الاباحيه
قبل ايام ما يعني حتميه توجيه اتهامات
جنائيه ضده
الاشاعات عن العلاقه بين ترامبوا دانلز
خرجت قبل الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2016
لكن صحيفه
نشرت تقريرا في عام 2018 عن مال دفعه
محامي تراب مايكل
كوهينز مقابل صمتها يقدر ب 130 الف دولار
وباعتبار ان المبلغ تم دفعه قبل شهر من
موعد الانتخابات يحاجج منتقد ترامب بان
هذا المال قد يمثل خرقا لقوانين الحمله
الانتخابيه فهل سيتم اعتقال ترامب حقا
ليكون اول رئيس امريكي يعتقل في تاريخ
البلاد بلال البجديدي العربيه
[موسيقى]